foi caro assim tá aí fui humilde e aí o
olho lá todos pessoal do que falar andar
que sejam muito bem vindos a mais um
vídeo e hoje o vídeo é bem diferente
está aquém tanto assim que o calor do
fogão
bom pessoal eu tenho visto ultimamente
youtube vimeo e anda na moda agora steel
vídeo que é que ser uma faca com estas
tochas
isto é uma taxa que tem acha que dentro
e quando nós ligamos o gasto chama agora
o que vou fazer hoje é que se esta faca
com estas tocha vai ficar provavelmente
mil graus milgrau mil grau é muito muito
quente vai ficar toda vermelha eu vou
tentar ser valores americanos portanto
acho que o conseguido e assim que o
facto de ver quente com 1.000 graus que
eu vou enfrentar 40 tablets circular
[Música]
eu já tirei que o papel é três tablets
só para ver como é que espera lei tira
tudo bem também é o queridinho não sou
muito bom chocolate é muito bom pessoal
temos aqui 40 tabletes de chocolate
acham que essa faca é capaz de cortar 40
tabletes e eu acho que isso já que era
facto eu vou estar aqui faca só pra ver
se ela corta bem ou sentar quinto caiu
ou fez um show até muito grupo tem já em
baixo se vocês acham que essa faca
quente vai cortar os 45 anos eu comprei
especialmente 40 chocolates mesmo que é
capaz de suportar todo e é isso que nós
vamos ver agora precisa buscar o carro e
não uma tabela no domingo 8 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10
aqui já tem de chocolates cara não sei
se vai dar
aí estava invertido meu olho aí ó
proposta e vem tudo o partido a que o
sol não fazem do sul quatro peças e
assim vai assim mais por aí minha mãe tá
tudo é que espanha só desembrulhar sucop
desde já deixem o vosso leque se
quiserem ver mais deste tipo do vírus
que foi pensar e saber partido meu eu
estou pensando em trazer mais este tipo
de conteúdo portanto se quiser ver mais
deixe mesmo o nosso leque de sol só
percebi isso vocês gostam e usou todo o
pessoal nós conseguiremos chegar até aos
50 mil à ex ministro vídeo eu vou cortar
o pé era eu vou cortar 11 mil iphones a
isso esta faca quinto eu vou tentar pelo
menos nessas 50 mil likes neste vídeo e
ocorre no iphone está pronto é só ficar
muito grande essa turco atuais 27 28 29
30 e 37 chocolate uma turma 30 tablet
ainda faltam 10
a lei já está muito grande eu sei o que
eu duvido que a faca corta isto é que
supostamente a faca vai arrefecendo a
medida corta né
então tive ela deve chegar atentado eu
acho
tá muito grande do sul eu tenho isso
claro o quadro de quadra e 40º 40º 40º
chocolate é que está a nossa torcida lá
pessoal agora o próximo passo vai ser a
que será faca e não façam isso em casa o
que eu estou fazendo aqui porque eu sou
um homem de 22 anos banho bem adulto
portanto eu quero fazer e vamos tomar
medidas de precaução antes da terceira
faca porque eu nem sequer sei como fazer
isso tanto é melhor usar luvas e óculos
e coisas assim tá eu nem sei se
encontram mas acho que a xuxa na
segurança
a lei proíbe o fumo só vou testar a faca
que essa faca bem afiada não corta não
corta engraçado dós notas muito reduzida
em 50
será que dá funciona a cair bom pessoal
as medidas de precaução tomadas ou
óculos luvas a fadas não posso usar
óculos isso vai manchar tudo
a lei começa logo a bacia toque pessoal
é que é a corte estamos sem proteção do
olho com muita calma por ela então a
terceira facada vou ligar os dois
posto isso sim é para aquecer mais
rápido muito brusco
acho que vai cortar
a gente possa contar que vai estar mais
na altura vai faca quente de mil graus
32 ou bora bora bora lá o foi tocar fogo
na época fogo
cláudio tadeu monteiro o rumo e parreira
torrador a gente tem toda a gente em 2 a
eu nunca saí do golfo com a lei já
custou 45 limpa a boca é mais a cheirar
o chocolate tema vejam só em um dois
três quatro cinco já cortou cinco
tabletes de 42 sentir muito quente
acho que tá bom a contagem 3 2 1 11
o assu tentar cortar a curva já não sou
um leigo não pode funcionar o quarto
colocado e disparando a cortar ainda
cortará ainda está cortando o cheta lixo
quanto time até se imporão em língua
solta a bomba
agora o papel pegava fogo
hoje está difícil 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 o chocolate ok agora atingimos o
dobro nós temos cortar 5 agora cortados
mais cinco está a cinco de cada vez
então agora vamos aquecer ainda mais a
faca olha só o que eles mais forte do
que gordura faca é bem grossa tanto eu
vou tentar agora fazer com um x-ato o
alan mineiro x até bem mais fina o que
provavelmente deve aquecer mais rápido
né a produção x até tem medida certa do
chocolate também vou tentar concretizar
meu deus quer aqui de que nós só
computamos 1115 testiculares tem
executado tudo esse é o objetivo
já ficava mas já sabem nunca façam isso
em casa ao cair nunca é perigoso eu acho
que já estavam nessa contagem vai 3221
um pai muito funk a cortar cortar cortar
ontem fui sócio 4 ficou aqui meu a lei 9
10 11 12 13
nós cortamos mais duas com um x-ato se
não haver um plano de falar que ia que
ainda tenta testa vejam só o sol e chuva
também ontem caramelo caramel aqui além
de queimadas
olha a água estava gasto sabbaga chance
ele sabe muito e gasol de 40 tabletes
nós conseguimos cortar três andamentos e
esta missão é um pouco impossível porque
isso faz muito fumo a cortar e eu lá em
cima tem sistema de alarme e insular
mosquito caro pois tipo vão chamar a
polícia e os momentos e eu não quero
isso portanto vamos ficar porque custou
4 mil têm muita fatia ainda facultar a
lei eu vou encarar que este o caraças
ven da china que ela fosse eu acho que
fica mais fácil cortar porque eu não
aquela muito dura o mestre não vai na
faca bairro fogo mesmo a lei não vejo
isso com muita fumaça originada na
irlanda a itália também pressionaram mas
estamos fazendo aqui depois logo na
volta a ficar de quatro
ele também estava no fumo para o autor
isso só comentei embaixo vocês querem
que eu faça com o restante chocolate
ainda tem aqui muito claro entender a
fazer qualquer coisa e olha lá ó lei
querem que eu faça constante 14 mas o
vídeo não acabou porque eu ainda tenho
mais objetos para experimentar a faca
que não tem portanto chocolate poder
chocolatão eu gostaria que mais duas
coisas que quer tentar ter o tempo que
estive nos carros flex é um boneco tem
umas coisas dentro estética um
tiranossauro rex anti-estresse eu acho
que eu ganhei aqui na esquerda é o
qualquer coisa sem torcida e como é
clássico poema viável eu acho que é
fácil obter não é só vou arrancar isto
que secou o começo e quase conseguiu e
tem esse bonequinho aqui que é um carro
de neve com levando dentro está em água
lápis rodar uma reação química buethe
punisse exclusão mas vamos ver
eu acho que o clássico é ter todo e eu
nem sei o que está ali dentro imagina
material inflamável que vai explodir
provocando eu acho que isso vai trazer o
costa e toda a faixa vai comandar
depois da silva uma no canadá e assum
preto nem a ok tá preparado cuba após a
contagem 3 voltou a pagar extra e 321
vai leiloar em manteiga meu lei muito a
bola e bateu andrey que esses boa sempre
gosto artístico vejam só o pessoal como
ficou foi a lei brutal neo executar este
boneco mas acho que já não vou porque
espaço fumo pra [ __ ] já está aqui um
cheiro a queimado muito agressivo então
é isso pessoal eu acho que vamos ficar
por aqui mesmo eu acho que já está na
hora de parar de brincar com fogo e já
sabem eu vou manter a minha promessa se
nós conseguirmos chegar aos 50 mil
líquidos neste vídeo eu vou queimar ou
eu vou queimar o meu iphone vou cortar
em alguma e com uma faca quente e vou
tentar arranjar uma faca melhor porque
está aqui não é muito boa e vou tentar
arranjar uma ktm minto e votar no meu
iphone mas 50 mil haitianos não querem
porque elas só espero que vocês tenham
gostado já sabem e do postulado vocês
têm dois filhos que provavelmente ainda
não viram e aqui em cima vocês têm uma
bolinha onde se podem inscrever se é
isso ao fique bem até a próxima